thank you all for for having me and
having me back i am an alum of stanford
and because i have a fellow classmate in
the audience i'll confess i'm the class
of 80 um so that was that was some time
ago and it's  it's really a treat in life
to be able to to come back to where you
started and and not to be sitting there
but actually to be standing here
so it's a real it's a real treat for me
and it's a real treat to be  to be
speaking here because working in silicon
valley st tvp bases you know what you
guys do is very well known throughout
our community so we talk a lot about
what's happening here we want to tap
into what you guys are thinking the
trends that you guys are  following so it
is great to um to be to be part of this
so thank you for having me be part of
this so the agenda that i thought i
would talk about is a few things
first i thought i would start with my
career it's a  bit unusual some of the
people that you have come speak here you
don't have to google to understand what
they've done me you find some things in
you google but you had to google to find
out so we look at my career sort of  as a
pet dish to talk about maybe a more
unique path forward i'll stand back then
and talk a little bit about venture
capital the benefit of being a venture
capitalist is you get the benefit of
pattern recognition you get to see lots
of
ofil
of fail
of a great opportunity to continue to
learn so i'll share some of that back to
you and then i'll end kind of with some
thoughts about how you all might think
about your career many of you in the
process of building your  career but
before i do i want to
doll
two good i'd say 55 60% that's great
that's great for those of you watching
the video and the other thing i want to
know is how many of you would consider
yourself with your students or  not
having stem degrees science technology
engineering math how many would fall
into that probably slightly more maybe
65% but not entirely that's great that's
great well i will start with where i
started which is stocked in
california has more to do with middle of
united states  in some ways it does here
coming here was very very different from
me the oldest of five daughters my
father come from a family of engineers
in fact my grandfather opened a research
center at mf field he was employee
number three he ran all the
instrumentation so really early  silicon
valley my father got three engineering
three engineering degrees from stanford
two me one two ce one me um when i told
him i was going to take political
science not only was he app but he
couldn't believe they called it science
he like where's  the science i get the
politics but where is the science so his
big focus for me when i was on campus
was two things one we came from a solly
you know middle class family his message
to me is that your inheritance is your
education there isn't  t to be more after
that in fact i took out big student
loans to get through stanford said it
wisely my
education you were and remains my
greatest
treasure number two he referred to all
of his daughters as the guys and for the
women in the audience  that was great
because in my business it's mainly guys
so i just respond whenever somebody says
hey guys come on i don't think they're
excluding me so so those those lessons
have stayed with me stayed with me
through life when i graduated it was  in
1980 lloy
l my fellow classmate
fellow
business we knew it was it was a hard
time mean it was a horrible recession it
was the last b recession i came from a
family where i didn't have a big safety
net financially not long after  i
graduated my father passed away so that
became very real as the oldest daughter
with my youngest of the family five
daughters with my youngest sister being
17 years younger she was a
child being able to care for me and help
my family was really important i was
really afid when i graduated frankly so
i wasn't in position to take kind of ris
that many people can and maybe even i
can now in life i really needed to get a
job so i ended up as i' been you know
cycling down  to university avenue to be
a teller during school bank at a bank to
help make money to pay for
stanford i looked around and one of the
places it was that had opportunities was
banking and you kind wonder why bing
bing and it was interesting end up tell
you there two things one is i cared
because i did i did need a job they paid
well relatively well i can tell you i
made 1000 a year shocking and that was
better than a lot of other people so i
was thankful for that but the  most
important thing and this will be a theme
you hear from me is i got to learn i
didn't know what i wanted to be when i
graduated you know stanford is not a
trade school school that teaches
toc
valu
at that what i wanted  to do and i
didn't know whole lot really about what
i want to do my father had been a civil
engineer he designed lev and water
systems where i grew up in stockton most
of the people either you know most of
people worked on the land a  few people
owned it i didn't have a lot of role
models i really couldn't i really didn't
couldn't picture necessarily what i
wanted to be and the thing i really
liked about banking was that and
early on in my  interview my first job as
i was one of my first didn't take the
job but i remember this guy i wish
remembered name because it stayed with
me around banking specifically he talked
about he was a senior vice president he
was a big guy and  he said been able to
have so many careers within banking and
he did so many different things when
the auspices of a large bank and in my
own career i was able to do finance i
was able to do marketing i was able to
do it i really  got to try on different
hats so i got to learn i got a job which
is what i really needed paycheck but in
particular i got to continue to scale
and and talk more about scale venture
part scale is kind of a theme that talk
about scaling  companies scaling us
individuals at 52 that's still an
aspirational statement for me i hope to
scale further but it really allowed me
to really start to scale and think about
about what i could possibly do my last
assignment in banking was what then was
called it was in  the early 90s it was
called interactive banking i had been
managing it taken
scif was think
tak so my hus worked at apple i had
obviously a lot of sense of what was
beginning to happen down here i' been
managing some it departments before then
and  it was great i went to talk i was at
that point i was one of the youngest
senior vice presidents the bank had at
that point this is of america this stage
and walked and he he said
take
r and i really was interested in this
whole  online banking thing but it still
90s i mean aol was just starting out and
he said you know if this intern thing
doesn't work out no one will blame you
itl just because that inter thing work
out well the good news is the intern
thing worked  out worked netscape it was
private clark the craig newark who some
of you probably know of he should be
would be a great teacher of you to have
here by the way he he's an incredible
guy really bright and incredible
credible force in terms of the community
these days as well just just impressive
he actually was an employee he was a
consultant because he was starting this
thing called craigslist so it was sort
of the wild wild west and once i got
bitten with that bug um going and
staying in banking was no longer  the
right place for me to be so at that
point i really was
ied to do wast
sw america ventures and it was great the
guy who had been running it understood i
had both finance technology background i
understood our source of capital at the
point at  that point was b so they
thought this was great you know so so
move on to do that that was 96 and you
know that stage when i got out of school
venture you know was really it had been
going for a while but it still wasn  't
what what it is at all today and
obviously that started leading up from
96 on right into the the big bubble um
that that you've all that you've all
heard about and i ended up getting a
great experience in the late 90s  i got a
quick lesson on on cycles late 90s 2000
post 2000 um that was sort of fast
forward i got to learn how to make
investments it's a very hard thing to do
it's a high risk business you don't
have a lot of data  to go on you have a
lot of belief there's a way to qualify
that investing judgment but that's the
best you can do so i learned how to make
good investment decisions i learned how
to make bad investment decisions and
hopefully to do more of the former than
the l learned how to be a board member
which is different than when i was an
operator when i was running things you
know and we had a group and we make
things
happen took one set of skills when board
member
ce
that you
do took a  while for me to get the hang
of that and and really learn to love it
again i get to continue the opportunity
to learn and particularly i think the most
luxurious thing about venture capital is
that i get the chance to meet people
like you who know more  specific area
studying you come in andare with
on
you other
things like you students get to sit in a
class and get to learn it is it's
phenomenal it's a great experience it
played to my strengths and later I'll
talk to you about how when  you think
about your own career how to think about
that i was good in finance despite the
fact i tried really hard to be a liberal
arts major numbers are really the
language that's most common to me but i
also like people
other is you know as  i moved in venture
i became the managing director of scale
venture partners and what we when my
partner and i founded founded what is
now scale venture partners in 2000 at
the peak of the bubble not for the f of
heart we you we looked around looked at
all the we some
people trust for and other thing we
did was each one of us to our strs and
one of my strengths being managing and
and building teams so one of my
portfolio companies is scale venture
partners like many of you who are or
want  to be
ceos i help i'm not the ceo of the i
have no more economics or anything else
but i help you know think about building
think about ching about challenges to
fire when you have to change are things
healthy do they need repair that  becomes
one of my one of my portfolio companies
and i love that that piece of what i
get to do for the for the firm you know
after then spending some time in venture
learning a lot from it as tom mentioned
got to be or asked to be  chairman of the
national venture capital association
that's an
industry group that does lobbying and
policy work in washington we talk a
little bit about that what i care about
there a little bit later but also sort of
speaks for the industry because we're
lucky we'  re in the middle of silicon
valley so many of you know what a lot of
what you know i experience and see buse
you're in the midst of it um here in the
rest of the country and certainly around
the world this is really not not  as well
known so i've spent time speaking at
places like michigan and tuck and
pepperdine and and and other schools
internationally spent some time speaking
in shanghai to folks and so it was a
great opportunity to represent the
industry i was the third woman in  40
years to have the opportunity to do that
that as chairman that is way above the
average in terms of percentage of women
in the industry it's I think less than
5% that would be obviously closer to
half or eight so a great opportunity for
me and  then my last task if you will
before i step down from that chh that's
a part nonit of thing i did in addition
to my day job as
jer to and that wasting to a lot of
work around inside ball things in
washington on frank and other  issues
this was an opportunity i was in a
meeting at the treasury department they
were going around the room and and
talking about how do you get more
capital to small companies that was the
theme of this this meeting we had the
treasury department i raised my hand  and
volunteer get a group of people together
entrepreneurs
inv fks sec et to brainstorm some
solution to make it
easier for small companies to go public
that was about 18 months ago a little
bit over a year ago we we put together
plan in front of congress  to to make
that happen it became bill got signed
about a year ago and i up in
ren the
president i
will say there more in that cr those
my people those my people it was fin got
to that degree but it was it was it was
a great opportunity for me and frankly
you know atale venture partners i'll
talk more about what we do but the best
part of what we do is getting to spend time
with entrepreneurs it's exciting what
you guys do is really what creates
growth mo away  as they they go to build
you know great big companies so you know
when I think about that ar of my career
so far again one of my themes of sort of
scaling and learning sort of what am i
up to now sort of two things one is
really focused on the next generation at
scale and I'm really proud of the team
and really proud of what I see in the
firm as the next generation leaders and
it's a funny time in your career you
know where you're sitting or at least
most of you are sitting your goal is to
build your own career and to hit a
phase where your goal is to build to
truly build somebody else and let
them step forward and you stand back
probably a lot like it is to be a
professor  at stanford and and where your
real joy comes from seeing them do
really well and and i'm at that stage
seeing seeing my partners do incredibly
well the other thing is i'm on the board
of silicon valley bank which amazingly
enough is the synthesis  between banking
and venture capital and the whole
innovation ecosystem and who you could
marry two things together so it's a
wonderful opportunity for me to excise
both my long-term background and and my
last almost 20 years in venture and
it's a great opportunity for me to  learn
it's really different than the boards i
sit on now the boards i now is a venture
investor it's you the owner the
entrepreneur it's other owners who are
typically investors maybe one or two
independent members but everyone all the
constituents are either in
h
weer to  owners of en silic bank i'm
learning a few things one is i'm a
fiduciary for people who are not even in
the building and i take that really
seriously i'm chairman of the
compensation committee you know for
those that follow public boards  that's
the hot seat right now and I take it you
know very seriously representing a group
of people who don't have as direct voice
as they do in the investments
that I make and that's just an
incredibly steep learning curve and the
other  thing again i'm used to smaller
companies where culture is an easier
thing to develop it's all of us in a
room it's groups this size that if we
spend enough time together we in this
room could build a culture well you know
silken valley bank is  a much larger
institution with offices around the
world how do you build and maintain a
culture in an organization that large
and it's great to see and it's an
incredible culture it's incredible
source of innovation for those of you
that are interested in thinking about i
think  that's one of the reasons in this
class about buildings go to their
website they have inc set of resources
for entrepreneurs they have something
called the accelerator program they do a
lot to help folks like you think about
how you might want to build build a
company videos  on their website so so do
go check it out so i'm still i'm still
learning and that's my schol ied doing
it here i to keep doing it
forever one i do slides was title
lessons learned and then i was re it and
say lessons i wished i learned earlier
so i'll share them with you because
hopefully you will learn them earlier
than than i did because now that i look
back they seem you know incredibly
obvious the the first thing is you know
am i a horizontal or a  vertical person
what do i mean by that i've heard people
say do i build cathedrals or do i hit
golf bs neither is good or bad but do
you want to get let's say a phd in
engineering and you really you know you
want to  be involved in in you know core
engineering core discovery core research
really important i mean we wouldn't be
here in silicon valley without
that the founders of google obviously
started out very vertical obviously
become very successful horizontally but
very good vertically or do you have what
i finally recognized in myself more
horizontal skills more about bringing
things together consensus pattern
recognition judgment execution sort of
moving things forward a bit more about
building building something so knowing
that about yourself early on is is
really helpful and you might decide to
start with one  and evolve again the
founders of google have larry and serge
but you know how do you how do you see
yourself and what is it that you really
want to do and be honest with yourself
about that the thing that that i
probably have learned the most in  the
last decade is is really understanding
not just what your strengths and
weaknesses are if you're smart you're
listening to people around you giving
you advice and you understand that but
you all got here because you did well
all classes you took to  get here i sort
this view that well if i have weaknesses
if i work hard enough i should be able
to do that mean i may need to study an
extra hour than you do pass that physics
class you know per week but if i take
that extra  hour i be able to do that
maybe maybe maybe i can't may i should
you know one of the things you
really
wish
was people that can think out of the box
and be really innovative and come at
things orthogonally that's just not me
so  what i figured out over time is
instead of wishing i was more strategic
or trying to be more strategic that's
pitiful i do the best when i make i
surround myself with people who are and
i listen for people instead of thinking
where did that thought come  from
thinking where did that thought come
from that might be interesting to add to
my thinking so actually embracing that
you can't be everything and that the
best people in any function figure out
how to compl themselves is incredibly
empowering and sort of fin liberating
you  finally finally get around to that
took me took me
longer the other thing and i got this
early on in banking in particular and
then i h on to it was the thought
one theas chose bing i had s of the
people i was me with i had  people that
would be champions and how do i think
about that i was listening to city arts
and lectures where secretary rice i
guess she's cony rice on campus was
interviewing sg le and they were as a
side part of that whole conversation
they were talking about mentors  and i
think it was cony who was saying yeah
you know i go do these talks and after
somebody comes up to me and says ment
and says to them who are you your name
and and i thought that revealing had
that happen and you always feel  so bad
somebody's really being vulnerable and
asking you to do that and this is how i
think of mentors in my career and it's
been incredibly useful first of all that
some of the people who are my mentors
don't know my mentors by the way i  don't
call them that i refer
to
ment w just people who give me advice
they were people who really believed in
my success they w necessarily tell me
what they thought was important perhaps
for them but really what might be best
for me and they  had to earn my trust in
that regard first i had to actually
spend time with them to realize he
really does care about what he's really
listening to what i'm saying he's
watching my strengths and weaknesses
that's probably somebody who i want
feedback from and i  actually built a
composite if i had a mentor it was a
composite people i wanted people who
are ul now people not only who are
senior to me but people who are junior
to me who give me advice i get and i
want people who are close  to what i do
and i want people who are further away
from what i do all of those things help
me put a good picture around me that
really help me understand what i'm doing
well and what i'm not i think having
champions in  your career are really
really important particularly early on
but think about that you know earning
their trust but earning yours too and
think about putting together
ment and you
all got and you got lots of compliments
and and you did well and positive
reinforcement really works well  the
thing that you have to learn early on is
make it easy for them tell you the
hard go to them and the conversation
with you know i really
want of the things they might tell you
might be personal habits that you didn't
know you  had twitches you know i tend to
speak to quickly i've heard that many
times i prob hear till the day i die and
it's always good advice to get make it
easy for someone to give you feedback it
is incredibly valuable if you really
listen to  it to get that kind of
feedback and take it on board and ask
for it repe it's hugely helpful the
other thing early on in
your
happen with you you don't know yourself
you also don't know what happen around
you computer science wasn't  a big major
on campus venture capital was nc really
in in 1980 the things that i've ended up
being able to do didn't even exist so
you know to have become too narrow to
early would have been negative my my
nephew is an emy  grad out of michigan
undergraduate masters he comes from a
family of artists really fabulous
graphic artists and early on he said
maybe i want to be from by the way very
small town in upstate michigan so again
not a lot of exposure just like me trav
city  is a lot like stockton and he
said maybe i should be getting a graduate
degree in architecture said why don't
you wait for a little bit and before you
narrow yourself down think it through
maybe do some get some some internships
think a little bit  more inter fast
forward he has worked for ser of
companies helping a design hardware in
technology you know a lot of the
companies in the valley and now works for
a company called htc helping them with
their mobile phones and he's helping
sort of marry the design  phase with the
manufacturing phase because you want to
design things that are manufacture
spends a lot of time traveling to asia
really feels like you know the world
right now is is oyer and very very
thrilled about that turns out to not
only be good vertically but have  some
great horizontal skills so again had he
decided to do perhaps nli he might not
have had the opportunity he
and last thing i would that i learned
and feel this more all the time when
you're interviewing for your first job
and will say this  to anybody who come
see me
one that you know the opportunity to
learn think about it when you
interviewing for that job not only are
you trying to press the person you're
talking to it's a great brand name apple
google facebook ibm
whatever
you to  work with you should be thinking
in your mind not only do i think this
will be you know a good job for what am
i going learn and will i learn from the
people i'm talking to sp again back to
that mentorship that championship all
that  i i strongly adv don't worry about
the last two or
3000 in fact i was very popular remember
this when i graduated from campus it was
very popular to go into investment
banking did pay more than the $1,000 i
made
not aot but more but i  was looking for
an opportunity where i could distinguish
myself a little bit more and where i had
the opportunity to learn and where i
felt i would have unique sponsors as
opposed to being in in kind of a class
where i was being guided through so i
chose  something that paid a little bit
less because i thought i could learn
more think about that tr it will repay
itself to you many times over over that
small amount of difference day one is is
not really not really gna matter so that
is a little bit about
ma
give scale venture partners what we do
so give you context on how we think
about startups i'll talk a little bit
about the industry because it's going
through its own little bit of change then
i'll talk a bit about how you might
think  about building a startup and then
I'll end with thinking about how you
might build your
own venture partners as the name
suggests we like scaling companies we
invest in early revenue technology
companies just as beginning to scale so
we might work with an engineering
founder  who might be building out their
sales and marketing team they may they
probably they do typically in our case
have revenue might be 100,000 though
could be as high as 50 million that's
rare for us the average is a bit less
than 5 million when we invest but  the
company is still figuring out can i sell
this product can i sell it repeated can
i sell it prof so we invest when it's
still relatively modest burn rate we
might be figuring out is it direct is it
indirect is it premium a couple i'  m
writing a blog for the wall street
journal i just did an blog on on pricing
you know that's a lot of what we help
people think through and that's part of
the experiments we run when we
initially invest the first phase of
investment is does the product  work the
second phase of the investment is can we
bring it to market can we get it in the
us how do we do that and then after that
we
later stage is ring it up and then
scaling getting that slope of that curve
to really b b  up we are thematic in the
way we invest that's our first
investment decision is which markets do
we think take off for us to make the
kinds of returns we need to satisfy
institutional investors we really need
to be in not just a company dom be that
ta  it you think with respect to to your
career as well we need to be you know
there has to be you know the wind has to
be at our back we can't just be in a
good the best company in an ok market to
get  that kind of doubling every year of
revenue 5 10 20 you know to 50 on it
really needs to be in a market that's
taking off so we're very thematic we
spend a lot of time and in fact we bring
stanford grad usually like engineering
and  some business background to come in
in the summer help us actually use
technology to think it through to
really get hands on to think is this the
market that's really happening now and
then think about outbound calling about
how do we find the best company in that
sector it might be n might still be in a
university we may watch it for a couple
years or is it already formed and a
little bit a little bit more mature and
then when we invest our partners have
all help build companies i help build
that you  know various entities with
within b ultimately took you know b was
the first bank online first bank to have
online banking you know grew all that
you know hundreds of people as employees
i have a partner who started at sgi and
then son and scaled their  finance
business from nothing to a billion in
revenue a partner that was chief
marketing officer at amd so people that
really know how to build things so we
really help you know again pattern
recognition help give entrepreneurs
ideas network things they can think
about within something they know  a lot
better and their experts on building
building their building their company so
that's what we do and say
tov and learned a the thing that we
learned aot that app to you all thinking
building companies now is how different
financing company startups is than it
was  20 years ago used to be sp a lot of
money to build the technology l of i and
then your goal was to get cash flow
break even that was that was the passion
over time so a lot of money went
initially and then get to the point  you
know get more revenue and and pass over
cash flow profitability we kind of turn
that on on our heads because it is so so
much cheaper particularly in the tech
space particularly in software to build
the technology that can be done with
really sometimes very l  capital the
initial testing of sales marketing where
we come in also doesn't take a lot of
capital you know you do a lot online a
lot of is done you know self serve
premium you know converting people from
premium etc doesn't take a lot  of
capital what really takes a lot of
capital is that
doe
can efficiently we can it's capital eff
it can get cash flow positive that's
when we start burning lots of cash
actually from a risk point of view
relatively low r stage we're burning
sales  and marketing dollars which you
can turn on and off we calibrate sales
efficiency within our companies and it
goes deeper than gap and happy to little
more that later we calibrate like a
dashboard it's doing well we really
burning we really to make this company
number one  two or in sector because
that's again how you build a big company
they're rare we've been lucky to be an was
sold a couple years ago to adobe for 1.8
billion company exa target went public
on the new york stock exchange the day
the jobs act  was passed in congress and
and that billion and half outcome lot of
you companies like bo
in really high growth company
it modest ams of capital and then
working to become dominant inning a
capital so almost takes that whole
equation ultimately obviously when you
go public you  need to converge on cash
flow break even but you do that a lot
later but again it's a very different
risk profile and even as an entrepreneur
again you're raising money later when
you're doing it at higher higher values
and and you're  doing it you again
there's innovation even what we do
trevor i think is teaching right now
aass class on this topic but again
you're doing it when it's it's a very
different risk profile so something we
we have gotten a lot more conviction
even over  over the last last couple of
funds i want to make sure i leave time
for for questions so i'll pivot a little
bit stand back and quickly on the
industry you've been reading the papers
you know the good news about venture is
it's a  small amount of capital it's less
it's of the assets you know invested in
in markets and venture
companies generate 21% gdp million
private js gives a sense of kind ofa
that comes out of this kind of
innovation going forward on the us
economy and why so many  other parts of
the world are looking to emulate what we
what we do here but we are shrinking we
are down almost 80% the venture industry
itself and that's one I'm most familiar
with by the way not the only place to
get capital talk that  in a second but
we're down 80% from the peak in 2000
raised when and i created our first
fund scale venture partners so a big you
know we talk when i show these slides to
talk about this run up in capital up to
2000  and then it drops off i always say
venture capitalist we like exits we just
don't like it when it's our own and and
that's true but it's it's the tree that
needs to be pruned it's the diet we need
to go on it's actually very healthy  not
just for us but for you because what
happened when there was too much capital
we form too many companies you competed
on price it was
mre
at
having competitors like i think it was
real estate b2b at the peak there were
hundreds of companies formed how  are you
gna succeed and stand out really just
there isn't there isn't an opportunity
so i think it's it's really healthy and
the other thing that i also think is
healthy is again more innovation around
the different types of capital available
that was part  of what we did with the
jobs act in particular angels which
really to me is back to the future
because a lot of venture firms if you've
seen something ventured if you haven't
seen the movie you should and somebody
on campus should should  uh show that if
you have it it's just fabulous but it
really gives you the arc and a lot of
those firms are about the same size as a
lot of angels are today so i see that as
back to the future angels are
experienced and and i  think really
helpful to folks early on for modest
amounts of capital and that that whole
ecosystem is is healthy and alive and
also crowd crowd funding we'll talk more
about that that's obviously still in the
process
through are ways get capital and by way
not  successful company necessarily needs
to be needs to be venture back i'll talk
about what we look at briefly and you
probably know this well when we heard
this many times we look at startups when
you walk in and pitching you know the
number one thing and  probably i'd say
the number one piece that is why
somebody fails with us tell you we look
at we get 5000 plans a year we l our
sales force you database 2000 we spend
time with 150 and we do si to 10 a big
wi  so you have to have thick skin to
pitch begin with but probably the
biggest challenge when it comes to
getting venture backing is is it a big
enough opportunity is it a large enough
market is it is it aan is it a product
is it aure way  doesn't mean you suc
take capital and think maybe you know
flipping it earlier to as a feature or
product to a company put in a modest
really small amount of capital and sell
it off that way but what we're trying to
look at  is is it a big enough market
opportunity is it a relevant team you
can be in your 20s you can be in your
50s you can be in silicon valley you can
be in indianapolis which is where exact
target is so you know you don't have  to
be we're pretty wide open we just want a
team that's relevant and and we're open
to to what relevance means is this a
winning sol that doesn't always mean the
best
technology does best technology does
always wi it's really what's  winning
solution and i will say that over time
the lesson probably learned in watching
companies and the way we now think about
looking at investments is really
understanding the user and the buyer
sometimes those are two different people
by the way but really getting the heads
not want  them to do and they to see in
technology
stud come use tech in of what a user is
thinking when they might use technology
and and also your business strategy what
kind of capital strategy do you have we
talked a little bit that wey figure out
why  now why the solution why you when
doing your hk the things that you think
about
number
mar is
it thinking about your capital strategy
early on i think is really important
part of it because by the time you're
talking to venture capital that's part
of  the mix that you need to think about
if you want to go after different
sources of capital it could be an angel
it could be it could be venture could be
friends and family but you absolutely
have to network into that into that firm
you know i when  i first venture every i
got i would i would think
so can't keep
up can what happens is that sends
somebody and says kate you know there
really special that looking at i don't
know if this person is in this audience
but a  friend that i grew up with one of
my next neighbors
stock te sent me her her son's name of
course i'm gna take a meeting with her
son so it doesn't even have to be tom it
can be you know a friend of  mine you
know but some way to network in a banker
you know silicon valley bank a lawyer
any way you can think of go do linkedin
which is i'm a huge fan of linkedin if
you read my blog i love linkedin i love
reading i love  linkedin and it's hugely
powerful us a network figure out who you
know we're always a few degrees away but
figure out how to get in and get in
front
you know we as you know as i talk to
you about investing companies in revenue
sometimes  what i have friends call up
and say you know it's a really early
stage company i know it's in a sector
you have a lot of experience in would
you give a presentation would you take a
presentation for this company again
really great for you that's a safe
meeting because i'm i'm a later stage
investor i want to wait until you have
revenue when tom calls me and says you
take a meeting with these folks early on
to help them figure out when they go to
meet people they might get money from really really really
help helpful to do
be optimistic but
realistic confident but not cocky that's
a fine line to walk if you come in and
say do you think this is a good idea
i'll think well if you don't i'm  not
sure i do so you really have to come in
with some conviction but cockiness is a
hard
line optimistic and realistic about
financing i told you numbers it's hard
you we to ra capital into our funds you
will have more doors closed on you open
and  you just have to decide that's a
normal ratio it's not you that's normal
be optimistic but realistic about what
exits there are very few that are big we've
been lucky to have two mullion dollar
outcomes a third that may be in the
hopper and that's very in the  last
decade i
think less 10 in market over
extrem rare so by the way you can have
an incredibly successful career having
multiple bass hits and a lot of ser
entrepreneurs do exactly that so be
realistic about that i'll end with some
thoughts about your
career first is and i'm proof of this
you do not need to start out as an
entrepreneur i mean it is it is
perfectly wonderful if you want to and
here because so many of you want to but
friend of mine adventure says think
about  whether or not an entrepreneur or
an
entrepreneur you have to decide if you
really have it in you because look look
at my ark i had no idea i'd be standing
in front of my dad would be so happy i'm
at the engineering school  he says you
finally made it into engineering um but
you know you who knew i mean i had no
idea that i'd end up end up with and
that i get this opportunity to do what
doing you you have undi risk venture
capital div portfolio  inv inan of fund
inv career you only have one to invest
it's perfectly fine and we love seeing
people with resumes in our companies in
venture that have done a variety of
different things all of them and again
we're looking for a compl of skills we
don't want everyone to be the same so
think about you don't have to do this
it's you know you see somebody like
larry page and of course you want to do
didn't we all but there are a lot of
people who  been successful who haven
necessarily
start start that way i've talked about
you know if you decide to go that way if
you don't decide to go that way keep
that aperture wide keep your options
open learn think about scaling yourself
think about in  either situation even if
this doesn't work out well will my
resume be better at the end and not just
on paper but i have learned something
that i can sit in front of my next
interview and say i what i learned in
this job is i  got to h people first time
i got h people what i got to learn in
this job is i met a lot of different
technology companies what i got to learn
this j is i got to learn the
competitive landscape in xyz market
think about that consciously  that will
give you good options going forward then
individually you know it's all about
particularly if you want to be an
entrepreneur network like mad i've talked
to you about the composite mentor that's
really important i've talked about
getting a safe reality check think  about
going to your banker go to your lawyer
go to your professor go to your friend
who's a vc who's maybe not interested in
investing in your sector a different
stage try ideas out on each other try
your ideas out you know pitching and
getting a safe  reality check is is
really great get that feedback make a
deposit into the karma bank the best way
to get help is to give it if you go to
somebody and say help me course you know
i a bleeding heart i want to help
everybody and you only have  so much time
and guess what you know when i'm running
along and of sudden there somebody
running along next to me and they're
helping me and pretty soon i'm helping
them and it just starts to become
really natural and when somebody  comes
to me and says i have something you know
just read this interesting article
interesting blog i think you should read
and pretty soon then we're going back
and forth and now pretty soon we have so
make a deposit in the karma bank it
really comes  back to you it's a great
way to think about think about building
building a network and getting folks to
help you um i'm gna end before i take
questions on things that are on my mind
two things are on my mind one i know you
be  shocked when i say this thinking
about leaning in
as a woman thrilled ch did but when i
think about leaning in i'm thinking
about everybody in this room and when i
think about what i take away from from
that discussion and the discussion
engendered is  that we each have to own
our own success and i think of not only
as leaning in but you've heard my bias
about aperture lean
wide think about you know where you go
aim and aim think
ande i
have the policy thing i am the most
passionate  about i think a number in the
room agree with is immigration
immigration
reform there is nothing and even when i
sat in the rose garden and i had
administration and canter st asking
because
such great dial people in silicon and
washington and by the way we here  and we
so frustrated because it seems so what
people in washington should do for us in
so obvious we think they should know
this they don't they don't understand
the world we live in we are small when
i'm walking in a senator's  office and
big oil is walking out i'm like an ant
even backing up all of
us all us need speak up
more
speak it imra
need
ed i have an employee ours who indian
educated from pune engineer business
educated at worked both into it and  and
for us challenges with green card is now
living in dubai and is a student citizen
of the world is how he says it to me
it's a crime
isan hasc skill and you know i really
think we need to look at immigration
broadly i come from  italian irish
immigrants that's part of what america
has been built on but particularly when
we think about the innovation ecosystem
you know keeping engineers entrepreneurs
people are building companies what i
encourage you to do so my call action
aot of active on social media to word
app  bates story people
like actually more meaningful and it may
be your own personal story it may be the
person in the class sitting next to you
who may not be able to continue to here
thre and concerned about ability to do
so that par that needs to be  told i had
dinner
sp of called 3.0 and he said you guys
are to tim we're not hearing you in
washington tell your story so i am
calling on all of you who have a story
to tell it is not too small there ar
enough  other people telling it and tom
said you know it's amazing we had a rag
group of people you know 17 of us who
put together the ipo task force for the
jobs act who knew that we would be
successful law you guys imra
that
lent venture cap  nvc national venture
capital asso
lob on behalf of not just the venture
community but most important thing to
lobby on behalf of are companies
portfolio companies so we go back and we
talk about patent reform and fda reform
and things like the jobs act so that's
one  but there are a lot of them technet
is active silicon valley bank is active
on behalf of entrepreneurs mark
zuckerberg is putting together a fund to
go back and make a difference in
washington more all the time actually
you know
and you find others if you follow
somebody who active on issues that we
care about follow on twitter steve case
steve case the founder of aol startup
entrepreneur obviously wi successful
really active in politics he lives in
virginia so he's in washington all the
time follow st you will to hear a of of
going
ons from
fks
where
where is the jobs act right now i have
a copy of it that actually just got hung
on my wall that got
signed
cool as a bill a law it had five chapter
chapters
may aspect of it and i had good advice
in this regard from sec lawyers i was
working with we actually make a
recommendation contract congress we were
prescriptive as to the securities act of
1933 and 1934 meaning we we edited the
language the day it was signed somebody
filed to go public i believe it was work
day filed to go public it was effective
then the rest of the bill
unfortunately was recom congress
to
reg d a i'm talking now sec geek
language crowd funding which a lot of
you might have heard about different
things that general solicitation things
that also help  companies throughout the
spectrum from early stage through
through late stage meaning ipo go public
those are still in the hands of the sec
for what they refer to as ring and the
sec is under staffed and under funded
which is the sec ch continues rightly
so speak  about and it's probably easier
when it comes to regulation to be
careful about changing regulations than
not so i don't know when those will pass
unfortunately because there's still a
lot of debate i know that dun the ceo of
the new york stock exchange is actually
back this week with the sec on an
advisory board basis speaking to them
about how to get some of these things
unstuck because what was great was this
was one of the few things that passed in
washington and it was bipartisan
it's
alloc you do here help  urs
business pressure on lo
cong yes in the back
men could give
ex
oh that's great yes i will so do we the
question was i talk about themes and
kind of thinking about what markets we
want to invest in do we have a process
for it  we do and i'll describe it and
secondly do i have examples of what
worked and didn't work we do have a
process that involves as i mentioned
university students university of utah has
some students that we worked with we use
executives and residents you know  we all
been industry we have a number of double
one of
my partners andy v actually is a
masters i got a masters in electrical
engineering took tom class here we have
a lot of engineering background but
we've all been inv venture now for a
while so we kind of you know in terms of
actually doing it we we rest year than
we used to be and so we want to keep our
freshness index high so we like to have
both users and developers of technology
again university students plus
executives and residents  folks that are
kind of middle who have been building companies
in technology work with us and help us
think through markets and we we actually
go off site multiple times a year we
don't talk about deals we actually
debate and we actually do more debating
about  markets than we actually do about
deals buse once we agree on the market
it's actually easier for us to identify
a winner both its opportunities and its
risks everything we do has high risk but
but we know kind of better what we're
looking for so we  really debate that
quite a bit there and now talk about
things that have succeeded and fail in
09 students helped us try a lot of
technology in what we called at the time
backup sync and share the idea was that
you could use the cloud to back  up data
than carbonite sync data think dropbox
or share think box and we were an early
investor in box and that is grown like a
weed and been successful for us and we
really use that this backup sy and share
concept as a way to go out and  we just
really mapped every company we thought
in that space we tracked them we track
dr do fising we we were looking at that
and tried to get to that we used a lot
of the technology ourselves i'll give
you an example of ones that  have not
worked out as well for
us you know we we did a lot in the
health space for a period of time we
stopped investing in health i did a blog
on this sadly to my point
separate
us these about different ways to go
about that  market we were using
repurpose drugs after new indications it
has been successful clinically it has
been less successful because the fda has
required so many more tests and that's
taken hundreds of millions of dollars
and taken many more years so that was an
example of one we believed  in early on
that we stopped doing a number of years
ago and one really successful we all
have we all have our successes and our
failures and we don't learn from them
really the
is
yes that previous question what are ths
currently onor or what  you focused on
has
a there so many things looking we think
you know i talk to you early we think of
the buer we segment the world we got
trends mob trend cloud tr those are
trend
you ty offers many more but we think of
a  consumer and we had done a to this
have done a around consumer huge markets
facebook you know consumer can go up and
it can come down a lot ofers to
entry it can be difficult
cons
enterprises div into of people
enter the maj business person like me
and we think of just a business user a
marketing person a finance person you
know ceo whatever you know and that
would be something like digital
marketing we loved digital marketing
it's been the gift
that's kept giving to us omn was online
web analytics exact target has web  and
now social marketing we a company we
just invest
demand bas is really targeted kinds of
technology we love that around business
user the other part we are really interested
in is the it manager and andy who's a
stanford grad is really taking the lead
on this and  we're really looking at a
lot of s of the backend to mobile and
and cloud computing so we invested in a
company called boundary that really
helps you an it guy used to have there
all their you know even in the early
days the web you  still had your apps on
your you know c now on amazon web
services how do i make that my store is
up now store and it's not on my premises
anymore how do i make it's right
boundary helps you helps you do that so
those are the  kinds of things that we
that we that we look at i'll end briefly
with maybe just to reinforce one more
time about learning for those that haven't
done the math if i graduate 80
know
and
believe i can get even at
54 i don'  t have an acl on one kn and i
have an acl in the other i'm going to be
going into stanford the summer to get
the one fixed but i still believe i can
get better and part of it is you know a
i like learning i  'm really into ms right
now and i love how i did my ac in
january but i still think i can do it
better and the point is i love the
learning process and i hope that for
all of you that are sitting here at
stanford take  with you for the rest of
your life it is a gift and it's what
will power you through a lot of a lot of
things so thank you so
much